okay we're gonna get started because
it's 105 so we're kind of just a little
bit late and we'll just kind of wait for
people to come in and make sure we are
mindful of people's time so maybe all of
you can sit down while we get started so
actually it's gonna make just a quick
announcement about you know what the
plans are for the boards and stuff
oh sure so we got a lot of questions
about this so let's just take one second
and give it up for Leah and Jill who are
doing a we're getting a lot of questions
about the boards we think they're
fascinating one of the things we're
doing at the end of today is will be
taking high-res pictures all of this and
we're happy to share them back to you
says they're good capture your thoughts
and they're a good opportunity if you
want to keep driving them forward for
some of the research collaborations okay
great so with that we're gonna go ahead
and get started so we have just like in
the morning session we have four
presentations today so john lee is going
to kick it off and then asa Shamsi and
then myself and then we're gonna again
take a 20-minute break and then
basically break you out into groups
again so don't forget that we have all
of these like post-its on the table so
please use them as freely as possible
and we put up some clean sheets too for
you to go ahead and put up okay all
right so with that we're gonna go ahead
and get started so our first speaker is
John and I'm gonna it's gonna take it
away great thank you and it's been just
a pleasure working with you today and
the rest of the conference has been
amazing what I'll be talking about is
trust in automation there's a paper I
wrote with a graduate student back about
15 years ago and some of the material
I'll talk about here is from that and
unfortunately that paper like most
papers has lots of problems and graduate
students and I are working on a an
updated version that hopefully addresses
all of those problems and the title is
important we're talking about trust in
automation but also trust through
technology so how you develop trust in
people that are represented or
communicated to you through technology I
think is important
research is sponsored by NSF NASA Toyota
c.src also a collaboration with JD
powers figures in this talk like to
acknowledge them these are my students
that make all this possible and this is
my super cute dog here in the textbook
we wrote we have a section on his
relationship with our Roomba which is
relevant here because sometimes the
stakeholders that you design for the
people whose trust matters may not be
the people you think and in this case
with the Roomba the dog is somebody they
should design for but I don't think they
do what I'm going to talk about first is
why does trust matter I think it has a
powerful influence on behavior
particularly as technology is becoming
increasingly a genic and smart second
what is trust it's a multi-faceted
concept attitude and I think also a
relationship ship so it's relationship
as well as antal how much should we
trust more is not necessarily better as
we heard from some of Eric's experience
maybe over trusting his Tesla autopilot
we want it to be calibrated with the
capability of the automation the
trustworthiness of the automation we
also want it to be aligned with goals is
the goal of the automation the same as
the person and then finally who is
trusted and who is trusting who are the
stakeholders beyond the direct users
incidental users like pedestrians may
not trust the automation we heard a
number of people concerned that they
would be able to keep riding their
bicycles I ride my bike I don't drive my
car I don't want to get killed I want to
trust the automation to keep me safe
here's an example of trust in automation
gone bad this is from the NTSB
investigation of the Tesla crash this is
kind of a mundane picture a little scuff
on the truck the other one is too
disturbing to show because it took the
top off the Tesla and the head off the
driver and what's interesting is this
illustration of the
of trust in the technology autopilot was
active during this gray period out of
the 40 minutes or so 37 minutes
autopilot was active these are points
the yellow is when there's a visual
warning the green is when the hands were
on the autopilot I think hands on time
was about seven seconds total so touch
the steering wheel drop down worked
beautifully for 37 minutes until it
didn't
person trusted the automation over trust
of the automation so in terms of why
does trust matter it guides behavior as
we see there it guides behavior in a way
that I think is underappreciated Don
Norman wrote a book on the importance of
emotion in how we relate Todd not just
automation but in general design Tony
DiMaggio has written a beautiful book on
the influence of affect and emotion on
decision-making trust matters because it
influences behavior it influences
behavior as we relate to technology as
technology becomes more human more
agentic it is more active and engaging
with us it might have a voice it might
have eyes when it gets like that we tend
to trust it tend to respond to it as if
it was a person a lot of work with Cliff
NASA shows that Trust is active across a
broad range of relationships it's
multifaceted as I mentioned before from
the micro how we trust the defaults of
our computer the spell-checking and so
on to kind of a meso how we trust a
brand we believe Microsoft is out to
protect us is on our side with respect
to privacy that's trust but also at a
macro level how we value money is trust
paper in your back pocket is worthless
it's all about trust as is democracy
democracy relies on trust I thought was
interesting Bill Gates was saying how
education is the core flywheel to
society and then he backed off and he
said well actually trust might be more
important I agree with him so what is
trust this comes out of
the collaboration with JD powers this is
a quantitative look at qualitative data
looking at a network of topics from
comments on a survey of people's trust
and automated driving I'm not going to
go through this in detail I become
fascinated in text analysis but I think
what's interesting here trust one mature
technology is improving it conveys the
idea that it's not just about technology
now but people also trust in the future
they trust that it's going to get better
that it's going to improve and one day
it will be sufficient so that's one view
of the complexity of trust this is
another view of the complexity of trust
something I'm working on as we speak
this is a kind of word cloud but based
on word and beddings extracted these
words from 16 items for subjective
ratings of trust so items from 16
different papers that present ways of
measuring trust subjectively so Likert
scale ratings these are all the words
from that and arrayed so that the
similar words are near each other using
word embeddings and then you map to
spread it across two dimensions and what
you see here is kind of a nice cluster
of things related to trust it's
dependable honest reliable sincere
timely correct
and then interestingly these are the
sort of focus of the trust the brand the
robot the technology so moving on to how
much do we trust this I thought was a
great slide from presentation yesterday
quote from your CEO on building trust
and technologies Crusoe completely agree
with that it starts with us taking
accountability for algorithms we make
the experiences we create completely
agree with that and ensuring that is
there is more trust in technology each
day I disagree with that last phrase I
would edit this to be more trustworthy
technology
you want to make sure the technology has
integrity and that is the important
point trust ideally should be calibrated
with its capability or trustworthiness
you don't want people just to trust your
technology more you want your technology
to merit the trust and that's why that
phrase calibration um one way to do it
is through transparency you make it more
obvious what the algorithms are doing
but there's a surface and depth
component of this the depth component is
how it's actually behaving the
reliability the dependability of the
system the surface is what's on the
surface the colors you use the font
choice that you use apparently lavender
if your car is infused with lavender you
will trust the autopilot more so that's
a surface feature obviously that's a way
of increasing trust without necessarily
increasing trustworthiness and that
could be dangerous
calibration through control this is
something missing from that first paper
I think is really important being able
to control and feel how the automation
is responding to you pushing it in one
way or another exploring it through that
is really important so this shows the
problem of this trust and
trustworthiness Trust is your attitude
trustworthiness is the capability of the
system ideally you'd be on that line of
appropriate trust what can happen is
hopefully you'll be here but you might
be here where you trust things much more
than they merit and this is the
calibrated trust you're in the Tesla
your hands are on your knees your eyes
on the road ready to take over at any
moment here is the reality I kind of get
a better picture but that person is dead
asleep in the car trusting way more than
is appropriate and Linda's standing up
so it means I have three minutes one
minute two minutes varieties of control
really important point here obviously
there's the pragmatic you're controlling
to achieve a goal it's also
communicative
you control to signal to others you also
control to learn about a system you tap
the brakes to see if it's icy but
control is for self efficacy control is
what makes us feel like we matter in the
universe so control is really important
Springsteen put it maybe best and in
driving this is really important people
feel like they want to be in control so
communicative control this is a paper by
Josh Domeier looking at the way vehicles
can signal to pedestrians it's through
controlled not just lights and arrows
and verbal signals who's trusting I
think this is really critical because
oftentimes we're just looking at this
the driver and some automated element
but really the driver is in a network of
elements that need to be considered in
total so it's not just the driver
trusting the technology but it's
pedestrians
trusting the technology it's those
incidental users out in the environment
and it's also not just the vehicle
technology but the technology that's
arranging the ride chairs and the people
who are riding in the car with you and
if you're a woman in Iran talk to one of
my students she does not feel like she
would trust a lot of the people that she
may be paired with guys that may be
paired in the car so who you get paired
with that network of your trusted riders
could be really important so with that
one thing to give you some food for
thought
how 2001 a Space Odyssey trust
capability started out good appropriate
trust highly capable system and then
Dave lost trust unplugged how but if you
take the macro view how was working for
NASA not for Dave how was working fine
at the end he discovered that Dave was
getting in the way terminated Dave or
tried to for the sake of the mission so
is that appropriate trust was how
actually working way should did Dave
loose trust when he shouldn't maybe
should have just died
let the mission go on but with that I
think my time thank you for your great
awesome okay yeah we clap sure all right
so it's gonna go around if you have a
question I hear and then and then Jesse
afterwards so one of the things that I
feel like we focus a lot on is
capabilities and then confidence and
capabilities of agents or automation in
general and it was really interesting to
me to see your previous slide actually
where it was capability and
trustworthiness warehouse capability
never changed it was highly capable yet
there were other aspects that changed a
trust and it was so great to see honesty
as well as one of the words and really
really we focus on capability but I also
want to know that that my autonomous
vehicle is honest with me it's telling
me that oh it made some mistake and it's
not quite good at handling pedestrians
being fair and maybe in many ways
reflecting my morals or perhaps ethical
ethics of a broader society being
benevolent and and we really don't focus
enough on it trustworthiness we very
often equate with capability so I'm
curious a little bit more if you could
comment a little bit more on that yeah
yeah great point and this is something
that as I mentioned that first paper
equates trust more than this really with
capability and I think that's not a
complete picture and I think there's
multiple elements of that but one that's
really important is goal alignment here
we're assuming that the goal that
classic how betraying Dave the goal
alignment was imperfect to say the least
right so trustworthiness part of it is
the alignment of the goal and the second
half aligning with asset was great I'm
still highly capable still doing what it
should with driving the goal alignment
is problematic so the pedestrians the
vehicles are not aligned with their
goals
in fact it's a game situation where the
driver and the pedestrian are
negotiating or competing for the
right-of-way more generally when you
optimize who are you optimizing for the
individual the traffic stream or the
traffic and the pedestrians so it's it's
complicated that way so I think as we
move into these more networked systems
the goal alignment becomes an element
that complexify suggesting has a
question then Dom before I get started
so we have a few new people here we have
post-its on the table so as you hear
comments because our goal is to try to
generate research ideas please jot down
some notes and plaster up on the thing
and if I see that you haven't written
anything well I'm gonna call on you know
just so Justin you and then Don go ahead
so John I want to hear about your idea
regarding the concept of calibration
so without go the standards there is no
calibration so I'm kind of thinking
about what is the good standard of trust
say now previously there is auto say
assume like Tesla autopilot works
perfectly but then suddenly you make
like an accident
so like the person's trust should
decrease but then on the x-axis
where the ghost and we know that gold
standard we should not trust it
completely but where the gold standard
will move and how to extend that you
will move so you're not gonna let me off
the hook with this aren't you we talked
briefly before and I thought I
sidestepped that all issue well but so
it is really complicated so this
trustworthiness one element that I
didn't mention is that there's a time
period to this it's a dynamic it's not
the same so with Tesla it can be really
good and you can have your eyes off the
road but then as we were talking before
lunch that car moves out and you're now
the head of the queue the capability of
that vehicle is dropped in some sense
and it should demand your attention to
the road so there's a dynamic component
that is really important to consider and
so I think the the trick there's two
parts that make it difficult to measure
is the time scale of trustworthy
and how you estimate that how you
quantify that and that's tricky but then
trust how do you measure that and part
of that measurement is maybe through
subjective scaling and that's why I've
pulled together 16 of these papers that
have different measures of trust but
also maybe more importantly behavioral
measures of trust and we've got a couple
papers looking at how people respond
like with vicarious steering for example
you get a sense of how engaged they are
so Don did you have a comment several
first of all I really like that diagram
and now abut because actually I think
the right-hand side the two dots should
be together because the real question is
who is viewing the diagram or if you
will when it says trust it's trust by
whom yes so capability is capability of
the device and Trust is trust by Dave
and so in in that sense the two diagrams
are correct but if you now say what is
about trust from the nasa's point of
view the diagram on the right should
have the two blues so they actually in
other words maybe an 8-3 diagram to
demonstrate that point of view is
critical in assessing trust the second
point I want to do is you can't make a
system that tells the driver what is not
capable of doing because it doesn't know
what it's not capable of doing and and
we have unexpected things that happen
which well the whole point about
unexpected things is first of all they
happen a lot and second of all they're
unexpected and but I think a really good
problem
and this I want to just say this to get
it in the record for the discussion
period there's the problem of trust and
over trust and over Trust is probably
the more difficult problem in many ways
because we work hard to cause people to
trust and as the Tesla example Anna
Medical examples show that's a problem
but how do you design display
and I would I would like to recommend
not using the word trust because that is
a very loaded term insan I don't know
what there was substitute is but I'm
gonna say effectiveness and one thing we
know is if you have a map and you show a
dot and that says where you are but the
system doesn't really know so suppose
you show a dot that's shaded and blurred
and and the radius is a function of its
uncertainty and the same philosophy
could be used for a lot of the
information in the automobile one of the
things that people are trying is the car
often for the test purposes shows a
picture of what it what the car can see
and with outlines around the object its
identified and that's often far too
complex for the for everyday people but
it's a start and I wonder whose the way
and the last comment is I know you know
this is for the record the the famous
Volvo accident the the car actually did
detect the pedestrian but but the
certainty fell below its threshold for
reporting but but if it could instead
give us a certainty measure one that's
not disturbing though because this was
gonna happen a lot but showing that yeah
I think I detect something but I'm not
certain something that indicates that
not the words etc so this is for the
further research discussion
okay I'm gonna like one more question
and then we're gonna let a sigh start
okay so there was a there was actually a
couple questions there the first one I
agree with you completely this problem
of interpretation here I think has to do
with goal alignment which was missing
from that first paper and a problem that
hoped to rectify and then on the the
point of uncertainty one of my previous
graduate students probably sup lit
actually wrote a really nice paper on
using sonification to indicate
uncertainty so background awareness
supported through auditory cues of how
the automation is understanding the
world I'm not sure if that's gonna work
when you want to play your Bruce
Springsteen as you're driving down the
road but it's a start so a big question
okay quick question for the transversing
is from technical side definitely we can
make a software and
we're more secure and more robust but
how does really like mapping back to the
house were saying you should be in a
conceptual level so so as you change the
make the hardware in soccer more robust
how's it reflected yeah so I think that
as you make the hardware and software
more robust that's going to increase the
trustworthiness of the system and then
hopefully if that's represented well at
the surface and depth features of
transparency and if you give people the
the right amount of control so they feel
engaged with it and understand it that
should increase their trust to hopefully
the level of capability that you've
given it you've improved or brazillian
see if I would stay would so I would say
it's it's supposed to be resilient which
i think is a good point
so resiliency robustness capability
words we should think about yeah so so
well so I think this is a really great
discussion that we'll have like as part
of the breakout sessions when we talk
about trust because it sounds like a big
topic so let's give John a round of
applause and our next speaker is AJ and
she is going to be talking for 10
minutes I hope so I'm gonna try to be
really quick I know Linda manages a
types of yourself hi everybody I work
with Eric and base and with Gaughan so
I'm gonna kind of try to cover I'd our
joint work in the space and I think this
is gonna be kind of a shift because I'm
gonna take more of an AI perspective
like as someone trying to build AI
systems what is the role of humans in
these systems what does that mean for
the self-driving car experiences we've
been talking about and what kind of
capabilities we should be putting into
AI systems so that they can really
utilize this human human-in-the-loop
having a driver in the car much better
than what the current systems are
capable of so to do that I want to start
with just overview of what a
learning pipeline looks like how people
are building machine learning systems
today and this actually includes the
self-driving car functionalities as well
if you ask commissioned learning person
how they are building these systems they
are going to give you a picture that's
kind of on the top I get my favorite
data I junk it up to a training site on
a test site optimize the parameters of
my model look at the accuracy if I'm
happy if that's better than the past
accuracy I'm very good
however as we are looking into real
engineering pipeline special to work
going on at Microsoft we are seeing that
humans are part of every step of the
development lifecycle and also they are
the users of these systems so humans are
a big part of how these systems are
trained developed they give the
objective functions they tell the
machines what they should be doing they
are part of the execution of the system
because every time I tested cars gives a
warning light and says please help me it
is actually getting a human in the loop
for reliability purposes and finally our
real goal is not really getting the most
accurate machine out in the field our
real goal is really having the machine
that provides the most value for the
human and that's I think what the
purpose of AI do all of it should be and
I will just try to make a quick case for
why we think about human in the loop so
much there are multiple reasons they are
quite general but I think they apply to
soft driving cars or semi self-driving
cars as well first of all unless I die
systems are perfect there are actually
particular complementary strengths we
see from humans and people we see this
in medicine but I think the car settings
are really interesting for me because
people and machines have different
sensors to perceive the world so it is
quite unlikely that something that is
failing the light out of a car is gonna
fool the person or when a lighting
condition goes bad and the human can not
really see much it's gonna be the same
problem for the machine so we really
want to see what that complementary
strength looks like John actually
mentioned the ethics the value judgments
question which is
no I'm not gonna no that's not my
favorite problem I actually feel that
that is a superficial problem that just
you know gets that gets us out of the
real problems but at the end but at the
end of the day do we still make value
judgments every time an engineer puts an
objective function into a system they
are making a value judgment it doesn't
look like the trolley problem but they
are making a value judgments about how
fast the car should be going if Miss
settings is ok to override the traffic
rules because maybe people are not
following the traffic rules as as it is
written in the books so all of those are
actually value judgments that are going
on into the systems we need people to
debug these systems and figure out how
they can be improved it data collection
and so forth but the main thing I want
to talk about today is the role of joint
execution for reliability we know that
the cars on the street today are not
perfect they actually fail a lot and the
only reason we can put them into the
world today is our reliance on the
people as collectors of these systems
and have that virtuous feedback loop
back to the companies because every time
a human corrects the Tesla car that's
the signal that the car or the bigger
company can use to improve the
algorithms for these systems so I just
want to talk about why these failures
happen and what is the reliance on the
human with AI algorithms requiring a lot
of data we rely on these kind of
platforms this is a aresome from
Microsoft this is a simulation platform
it's available for drones it's also
available for cars a lot of the car
companies are using these kind of
simulation platforms and reinforcement
learning to build the algorithms that
are that are going into the cars today
and when you look into it it is nice
nicely lighter there is like a street
the car kind of bumps up here and there
and then finally learns how to drive
however this is how the real world looks
like this is quite different than the
simulation platform this is the screen
from the uber car when you know
unfortunately the car killed somebody
a pedestrian during the drive so what we
are seeing is that there is this
mismatch between the simulation platform
and the real world
no simulation platform can capture the
complexity of the real world and because
of this mismatch our current algorithms
have blind spots in them they cannot
really learn all the features that are
important to function in the world and
when they get into a space where this
kind of this outsider that is not
represented in the simulation is in the
real world they fail and they have no
idea that they are failing
so these kind of confidence scores being
able to signal a person they completely
go out of the window when we have these
kind of mismatches between the training
platforms and the real world so what we
did in this particular research paper
this is just one step towards giving
people given computer systems the
capability to know what they don't know
is we actually used human data human
demonstrations in corrections to teach
machines what they don't know build
these maps of confidence and then use
them to be able to hand off decisions to
humans of course right now this is all
happening in small toy problems that we
can kind of do in our machines right
this is not real self-driving cars but I
think this is one algorithmics that we
are taking to enable the machines to
know more about their capabilities but
the problems in this driving space are
not limited to machine blind spots
humans have blind spots too this is why
we are excited about the prospect of
self-driving cars what you see here is a
human blind spot so we should really
think about where machines have blind
spots where humans have blind spots and
really have algorithms that can reason
about both together to really think
about control very much so in our follow
our work what we looked into is really
like how many can collect data both from
the machines and humans bring it
together so that we can map out the
space of complementarity really figure
out who is a more reliable I know you
don't like the world I think it robust
was the word right reliable is the
guitar who is a more reliable actor in
this situation and we can manage the
control that way so the last point I
want to make is that unless we can
really make those kind of algorithms
work and build agents that have a good
understanding
of their capabilities we rely on humans
and we rely on their trust so the the
way that when I talked to Eric about his
experience with the Tesla the way he
describes his experiences that he
watches the car he watches what the car
can do and cannot do and true that
humans build mental models of trust and
they say in the street I can trust a car
I don't have to watch over a lot but I
know this exit is problematic and it
does exit I said I should be watching
over it very carefully however all of
these cars like any software gets
updated all the time it is just one of
the problems that we have when humans
and are in the loop but our AI systems
are not designed and optimized for
having human in the loop these objective
functions were updating models have no
consideration for the human thrust it
has no consideration of the human mental
models and when that happens an update
can actually kill the mental model of
the human so there are actually a lot of
new insights we should be putting into
the development of AI systems for them
to be human aware human considerate
through the reason about new capability
is going beyond of accuracy that can
sustain that partnership between the
human and the machine so we did a little
bit were overcome this with gagarin and
we are continuing our collaboration
right now where we looked into the role
of updates machine learning updates in
the human AI collaboration so the
expectation is that I have the blue
agent human learned about the blue agent
the green agent is a better agent I move
to the green agent together we get
better if things are not compatible
if the updated agent breaks the mental
model of the human this is a situation
we got and we actually verified the
situation with human experiments and
what he can do is actually add a term
for dissonance into the objective
function of the machine learning model
that penalize --is these kind of new
errors errors that break the mental
model of the human and actually can get
machine learning models to be compatible
with human expectations so this is just
one way
can be more considerate be more human a
very in the development of AI systems
and why this is important because unless
we can get perfect AI systems in safety
critical situations we have to rely on
human trust they are our key for
reliability that is why we have to
really think about the human side in the
development of AI systems and that
requires think about the humans from
design to the development of the
objective function thinking about the
improvement loop be developed in our
engineering practices so what we are
doing is that the original objective
function for machine learning models
only care about the curious in a data
set what we are putting in here is that
a term for dissonance that is actually
penalizing every mistake I will get
there but I need to explain this first
ok so what this is saying is that
whenever you are making a mistake that
you were getting before that human would
trust you it I'm giving you an
additional penalty term so that's what
the objective function does and this
compatibility score is actually watching
that it's watching how many of the
things it was getting right before it is
getting right now so how much are our
trust is capped or broken this is like a
percentage and y-axis is the accuracy
performance of the eye algorithm the eye
out a eye algorithm is going to be most
accurate if it has no compatibility to
the past it can just optimize a whole
lot of the data sack so that's why the
points on the tab so the three lines are
different optimization functions
different dizziness terms we study in
our paper but focus on the blue one
because that seems to be doing the best
what you see here is that you can you
can you get most accuracy when your
compatibility is low but you don't have
to sacrifice actually a lot of accuracy
to get to a higher level of
compatibility you can kind of continue
that function quite a bit but if you
really want to get to a lot of
compatibility
you have to start a crow fighting
accuracy so our idea is that we want to
give these kind of graphs to AI
developers when they are going to be
updating a system they can look at these
graphs and actually they can say this is
the point I'm building to be I have to
be at this accuracy that means I have to
I will have this much compatibility with
my past models and maybe I'm gonna have
a strategy to communicate what has
changed to my human user and they can
talk more about this at the break or
something up there yeah great thank you
very much okay this is it thank you all
right so we have some time for some
comments discussions questions anything
okay John well hold a minute mmm-hmm
really great talk
you mentioned dissonance and the degree
to which it's compatible how do you
quantify it what constitutes a mental
model breaking change versus something
that's just different that might not be
noticed it might not matter for the
person that's a great question we are
kind of taking a kind of simplification
approach there what we are doing in this
paper is actually saying any time you
were getting right before I assume that
the human has learned to trust you with
those and if you are that you start
making mistakes on those instances it's
going to be really problematic because I
had trusted you now the machine is
making a mistake and I'm not going to be
really aware of that mistake I'm not
going to be able to correct you however
in many settings in practice people have
personalized experiences so they develop
trust in different ways their
experiences dictate where they are going
to be trusting more or less so actually
the best better way of thinking in the
future which we don't know how to do yet
because we really don't have
computational models of trust or mental
models yet would be really thinking
about the personal experiences of people
try to model what that trust looks like
and put that as a component into
backwards-compatibility
I also want to again remind people to go
ahead and put up your post this and then
Andrew
walk around and take a look at them so
if you have post-its and you haven't put
it up yet please do I guess no more
questions alright then let's give her
one more ham AJ and I'll next speaker
now is Shamsi give me a few seconds as
it gets
yeah you know what let's take this time
to write some notes like write some
research use these microphones forget it
things done yeah go for it
yeah multitasking micro tasking yeah
okay all right I think Shamsi is ready
now so I'll give people a couple of
seconds to finish their notes and we can
start at a private point yes okay ready
let's go okay so I know that Linda
started her stopwatch awesome I already
lost two seconds so we are going to move
from automation and Trust back to work
and we already had some very fruitful
discussions during the first session in
the morning and I'm going to continue on
that and kind of like talk about a
couple of projects that we have done
about work in the car or in the context
of when you're commuting so oh yeah it's
nice to have this now so again getting
things done is no longer confined to the
desktop anymore because we're commuting
we have mobile devices that have
increasing capabilities we can basically
carry work with us everywhere it's not
necessarily a good thing it's just that
we are starting to have that capability
more and the key point that also came
out today is that we are spending a
substantial amount of time commuting and
think about the cities of today is that
people are being pushed more and more
out into the suburbs which means that
they're commuting more some people have
remote working capabilities most people
don't so that is kind of like lost time
in productivity and so we're thinking
about can are there opportunities to
make use of that time and that's kind of
the core of this entire workshop so we
know that driving is no longer a single
attention task and I just wanted to
point out like for scenarios which I had
also briefly brought up this morning so
I'm not going to belabor over this
primarily manual cars continuous
attention is driving and we could have
opportunity interleaving of other tasks
we have talked about this this morning
connected car where is that you just
have broader range of multitasking
capabilities because now you can talk to
the internet and and the cloud
semi-autonomous and autónoma so I know
that someone had talked
it being more about self-driving cars
versus non but there's this weird spot
where self-driving cars are not always
self-driving and so that's where driving
becomes secondary and you have to
interleave just like paying attention to
the road so that you're ready for take
over and then finally autonomous where
cars drive themselves you have
potentially full use of the commute time
but there are other design
considerations around that so this is
the Cinematheque environment it's moving
and all of that so we talked about this
in the morning we all know that engaging
in something is intentionally
challenging and how do we design tests
so that it can deal with that limited
attention scenario so there is a
flipside we know that we do a lot of
mind wandering when you are driving
because typically we don't have anything
else to do so driving sometimes become
so automated that you can allow yourself
to think about different things but it
also means that mind-wandering can
negatively impact your focus on the road
and it's kind of like how you're able to
control your conscious thoughts that
gets lost so there has been research
that shows that strategically-placed
concurrent tasks during your driving can
actually help people be more vigilant
and focus on the road better so there is
some opportunity there we listen to
music we try to talk to other people so
that we are alert and not falling asleep
so there are also and I had hinted at
this at in talk this morning is that
there are moments during the driving
where we feel that we might be able to
handle things better than other times
during driving that we know or at least
we should know that we can't handle
others tasks and they're thinking about
new experiences for semi-autonomous and
autonomous vehicles is that what are
some of the things that we can do in the
car so I like to think of this as kind
of like these four aspects so one is
that what are some of the non driving
tests that we can safely do in the car
now if I tell you that yes go ahead and
write your KY paper in a car which is
not self-driving that is probably not
the right thing to do but we're already
doing some of the things in limited
attention environments and we have now
assistants that are making their ways
into the car that are potentially going
to help us with some of these things
just because an assistant can help you
doesn't necessarily mean that it the
tasks are designed in a way that it
should be presented to you
in the car so I think that there's a
design opportunity there is that your
assistant that helps you at home like
Alexa or see the interaction there is
very different than what the interaction
in the car should be and so that is also
another design opportunity we talked a
lot about microcast this morning about
kind of like thinking about tasks that
do not require sustained attention and
can we how can we break it down to a
level where it makes sense for the user
to do that task but also take away that
inter dependency that well the next has
that I'm going to do need this task to
be completed before I can move on to
that one and then finally and this is
this is also an area that is ripe for
research is that we're not only
designing for drivers in the car we are
designing for sometimes the passengers
my Highlander does not let the passenger
actually put in or interact with the GPS
system when the car is driving so I'm
not driving so I should be able to do
that but it doesn't let me but also
thinking about I mean a passenger in a
driver in a self-driving car is kind of
like a passenger and that's assume
that's fully self-driving but again it's
a moving environment how do we design
especially in keeping in mind things
like motion sickness keeping in mind the
resource constraints and all of those
things so I want to talk about two
projects the first one was not
necessarily done with the current mind
though it was motivated and the second
one was we really wanted to push the
boundaries of thinking beyond just the
communication level tasks so this is
interesting because I know this morning
some people talked about kind of like so
I want to not necessarily carry on work
all the time I need to be able to detach
from work at the end of the day and
particularly people look at cars being
the place where people start disengaging
from work and they start ramping up to
home so that was my motivation about
thinking about okay so how do we kind of
like use this time as people are
transitioning from home to work and work
to home for to allow people to disengage
and reattach to to work after a while
and there is there there there is
evidence in occupational health behavior
and organizational
occupational health therapy and our
organizational behavior which shows that
adequately being able to detach at the
end of the day actually helps your
productivity in the long term and
reattachment when you come into work
probably everyone starts off with
checking their email getting caught up
with the things that they want to do
taking maybe their to-do list and that's
where kind of like you are spending
maybe half an hour trying to get get
ready for work and so we were thinking
that can we move some of that some of
those actions out from the desktop into
when you are coming into work so we
developed a conversational agent that
asks only a couple of questions at the
end of the day to help people disengage
and then brings back that information
the next day as they were walking into
work and so that kind of like to get
them get them in that frame of mind this
agent was not used in the car so I will
make that claim right away and part of
the reason is that we didn't want to do
that study in the car we wanted to see
how effective these questions were so it
was set up as people could use a Skype
client to actually interact with the
agent but it could definitely be used in
the car and I'll show a video in a bit
and these questions are super simple
what did he do today what do you want to
do tomorrow and how do you feel about
work today and how do you want to feel
about work tomorrow and the next day it
just brings back that information and
asks you what is the first thing you
want to do to be able to do that so I am
going to quickly switch to a concept
video and what is this
yeah it is I did open it but you know
what just I thought I could open two
instances hey Cortana hi Alex so I know
you had a big day today how did it turn
out it's only pretty stressed I had a
few things to do today
I made edits to my paper I finalized the
study design for my study and started
the code base for the new project that
we're working on it I might be able to
help with some of those things if you
had to put one or two things that you
want to do first what would they be I'd
love to get the bugs addressed by noon
tomorrow cool I said a reminder to send
the email to Kelly for tomorrow morning
and it looks like you have an hour free
between nine o'clock and ten o'clock do
you want me to block that out so you can
work on the bugs sure that'd be great
done and done
we can revisit the other things tomorrow
so again this is a concept video this
does not exist it's not at this level
but this is kind of like a showcase what
we are envisioning with this and this is
Alex the intern who worked on this
project so we thought it would be nice
to showcase it
Warnock Ratana good morning Alex did you
sleep well not too bad and I'm ready to
get started let's do it first off
remember to email Kelly when you get
inside any time and now's the time you
set aside for those bugs if you want I
can hold any emails that aren't urgent
until after 10 o'clock
would you Thanks ok so that kind of
showcased what we are looking at in
terms of this experience and so you
might notice that it was totally speech
based and it was kind of these short
interactions and it sounded like a
conversation that you would have in the
car now we then wanted to take this a
bit further and see that well can we
push the boundaries of things that we
can do in the car and I see God looking
at me and so so again this is an
experiment we wanted to and this was
particularly motivated by the fact is
that we can take these bigger tasks and
break them down into micro tasks and so
are there parts of a bigger task around
PowerPoint or around document editing
that we could actually present in the
car in a safety aware manner so this is
kind of like a simulator that we use and
this is very conversational so this
again to just highlight that this is not
what we intend to do and no we and so
when you think about non driving tasks
for the car so again this is a speech
based interaction that we're looking at
it conversational agents could be there
getting better but you could also embed
awareness about safety because a lot of
information that these agents could use
is coming from the car so what is the
car speed what is the environment around
it we could use sensors to be able to
figure out what the cognitive load of
the user is and so we could use all of
that information to kind of filter the
type of test that we even allow the user
to get engaged in so again that's where
micro tasks come in and
have discussed what we think about micro
tests so they're not necessarily at the
very level where it doesn't make sense
anymore but things that people can
quickly do without having to depend on
that has before other tasks after and
again alerts were the other options that
we're thinking in terms of the safety so
I'm going to show another concept video
because I think that that showcases what
we were looking at Nick is working on a
presentation he is about to deliver in a
meeting
imagine Cortana keeping track of where
he is in the presentation and helping
him with the final touches as he drives
to his meeting while also making sure he
drives safely where were we you were
working on the motivation slide
perfectly
okay I'm ready the title screen says
motivation do you want to add text or
graphics on this slide I found a picture
and added it there is a bicyclist to
your right
do you want any other text on the slide
no I'll speak over it okay that's done
check this slide before your
presentation in case you didn't see a
picture of an autonomous car is
automatically inserted there so again
we're nowhere near this but in in the
future we could imagine our assistance
beings as smart and so that they can do
these kind of things for us but one of
the things the other things that I did
want to point out that is that if you
notice that interaction is very fluid it
is allowing the driver to pause it's
completely speech based of course there
are questions around okay so I am now
working on my presentation or even
thinking about my presentation and so
now I'm visually starting to think about
it and how is that going to contradict
with my driving and so of course there
are those kinds of scenarios that we
have to think about and that's why
designing work for the car is so
interesting is that how do we how do we
suggest these micro tasks and how do you
kind of like get a measure of what the
cognitive load is going to be and how is
it going to going to interfere with with
current work so the research questions
here and I'm going to quickly go over
this is that we wanted to see how the
secondary task structure or how the or
how the micro task is being presented by
the way the agent how does that impact
people's performance and the context
supports so the support about the road
how does that how does that influence
the drivers safety needs as well as
there needs to be productive okay okay
so very quickly people yeah I'll go
probably gate will go here driver seemed
to be split on the test structure
question so some people like the agent
to be kind of like very very directive
and they would answer the questions like
okay does this slide have a picture yes
or no
other people hated it and they would
rather prefer that I would dictate
something go and make it work the good
thing is that the drivers did not think
that they could create polish documents
nor did they did they think that they
should but they felt that whatever they
were dumping in terms of thoughts would
be useful to carry on later many rather
said that even though they might not do
something that is coming from the office
productivity suite they thought that
just thought capture or creating - duze
would be a good thing to do in the car
I'll skip over this and it's kind of
like implication for design is that
support for safety is important these
environment so it's not your regular
desktop environment neither is is that
your mobile phone environment when you
are moving when you're on the go tasks
should interleave with driving and so
the tasks should be designed in a way
that that they can be easily not only
engaged in but you can also disengage
from them very easily and there are only
some tests that are going to be driving
driver friendly friendly and trying to
put in everything into the card that's
not going to work and on that happy note
I'm going to open this up for great ah I
think that's great
does anybody have questions discussions
and don't forget to write so quite a few
Wow so yeah let's do that
hmm start with Duncan great I really
liked the PowerPoint theme while driving
it's nice idea so what is it kind of
react there's middle moments of like
going for a I think of going for the the
scenario you presented there was a
person driving to the meeting and to me
that's like standing up and going for a
walk and getting some distance from the
work and it's interesting that you chose
to focus in on the folk on more edits
being done it was like about adding
content to the slides or the kind of
stuff that you would traditionally do at
the desk whereas I don't know my
personal reflections on how that goes
down usually is it's when like the the
talk is rehearsed in your head and
you're reconstructing that high-level
and I'm getting nods yeah you're agree
construction that high-level narrative
and so it's interesting that you chose
to the interactions they're all about
put this figure in add some text here
whereas you could imagine an alternative
here where it's like you're talking
through conceptually what you're going
to be talking about the structure of it
all and things are being rearranged the
slides and cells are not being edited
but they're being real
range conceptually the overall structure
of the talk is a different level of
abstraction it's it's definitely that
and I think it boils down to where we
felt at that point what people have the
more cognitive load and from my personal
experience and I have used the car to
actually rehearse stuff and those are
also the moments when I have felt that i
have had no awareness of my driving are
you managed to manage to reach from
point A to point B I have no
recollection of how I got there
so which is which is scary but but I
think it's a good point thinking about
okay so what are the things that would
not require me to have continuous
attention on a test that is not driving
if you if we go back to the self-driving
cars I think that that's actually a
perfect scenario I mean it doesn't
require you to visually get engaged in
anything so there's no no setting of
motion sickness but it's a perfect thing
to be able to do in those kinds of
scenarios but I think it's also personal
dependent Andrew so this is really cool
and I really like the fact that you have
an assistant who's thinking about
helping and I wanted to point out that
you know data both in experiments as
well as looking at data about crashes
shows that having a passenger decreases
your chances of getting into a crash so
is it because of you know what kind of
interactions go on of course you don't
quite know but the fact is that you know
having a passenger probably means
talking to the passenger right so one
question would be how would you do this
task if it was in Cortana but it was you
know you and I are sitting there you're
driving and you're telling me what to do
and it intuitively feels like you'll be
pretty safe so I'm really always curious
about how we might be able to learn from
those human human interactions and
improve so I don't know what your
thoughts are yeah I think one of the
things that also came from the previous
talks is trust in the system so I mean
right now I wouldn't trust Cortana or
Syria or anyone even I may or may not
trust a passenger in the car so it's a
matter of when you are thinking about
manual cars you you always need to be
vigilant for yourself but also learning
from these interactions between
passengers and drivers I mean so
passengers would point you to things I
mean I would say an alert passenger
would point you to things in the road
that okay so keep an eye on that or
maybe talk or maybe
the amount of cognitive load that the
conversation is having so those kinds of
things I think there's definitely these
things to learn about there but there's
also some good points about systems is
that they can do some measures that
maybe a human can't so if you're looking
at wearables you're looking at all the
car sensors that could be put in a car
and awareness about okay there's traffic
coming up or they're distilled Road has
suddenly changed in terms of the density
of cars so those kinds of information
may be a passenger may or may not be
able to pick up on but a system might be
so one of the questions for me is sort
of what does it do to our very close as
a whole so I have done some of those
scenarios with a human assistant so on
the motorway going from my email and
quite regularly and I find this even
with a human assistant who is very well
knowing what I do extremely tiring so I
usually arrive and I feel I have done a
lot of work so I did this very often on
longer motorway tribes like one hour and
I felt this sort of I I arrived at work
and I felt I had heard sort of for a
number of hours so for me the question
is this sort of is putting this into
that context of trying has anybody
looked at what it does to our perceived
route load so I think these things and
if you study them in the lab that's a
different thing but so it's very easy to
study them with a visit of us and my
feel is sort of you feel at the
beginning this is really working
extremely well but once you arrive in
contrast when I have listened to music
or - yeah podcast whatever sort of I
feel quite relaxed when I arrive and so
so technically there's not really a big
difference but I find it quite taxing
doing that and so so did anybody study
that
yes so we me and you or it and John we
actually have a National Science
Foundation project trying to look at
trying to understand how much of a
workload it is to actually do work and
what is you know are we attribute but
it's the the package attack right that's
a good point so so Linda can you repeat
what he just said so what he was saying
when Albert was saying was that it's not
just about the moment to moment you know
interactions but it's more of the big
picture and then long term what is the
effects overall all right so I would add
one point to that and so I mean in case
there is a misconception so I am not
proposing that we do more work in the
car but there are seen and if you look
at the first one that was actually
helping people disengage from work so
that on the way home you're not really
thinking about work anymore you can
start ramping up to getting to home the
other is sometimes there are work
thoughts that would be there
automatically and so what we're looking
at is that are there effective ways of
getting those thoughts captured so that
you can actually you are able to relax
and you are able to listen to music
rather than thinking about oh I have
this meeting with Eric and I have to
think about all the all the points that
I need to make during those meetings so
I mean that that's one that's at least
one of my motivations to think about how
can we use the time in the car
effectively but definitely thinking
about the well-being of the person
that's another key part of the research
that I do
so just to repeat basically what he said
was that you know once you know we have
this feature and we're able to use it
our employees may actually demand us to
do it and is that a good thing or bad
thing from an ethical perspective we're
just gonna take one more question
IRA okay it's flora from Melbourne RMIT
so thank you sir I'm Geo I wish my drive
scenario looks like that it's very
relaxing but the thing is when I think
what what is missing really is a lot of
toss happening especially in the first
and last mile of the drive so for
example give you a couple scenarios for
example I know now the traffic's
building up and I'm going to be late I
have to find a car park where I usually
get my train to work right and I know if
I'm not catching that train in five
minutes I have to write that email to my
ten o'clock meeting say I'm going to be
late and there will be repercussions
along the way and I have to say much to
my students maybe hey I will have to
cancel my meeting with you because my
ten o'clock meeting is delayed blah blah
blah a lot of things happening in my
mind so these are Democritus and I think
that's this I think I personally think
we're still far away from the scenario
of drafting our document but I think
these are the low high low hanging
fruits that we should be tackling so my
question to you is have you explored the
sort of taxonomy and categories of tasks
these micro tasks that people might have
been thinking while they're driving so
it could be I mean we've export
something like this in our other
projects but it's something maybe it
could be a navigational task about okay
where to find the closest carpark is it
something to do with finding something
is it a finding toss is it a searching
for information so this kind of little
little micro toss so this morning that's
fine what people want to do in the car
then I I believe that some of these
communication needs came up and the
scenario that you described I think
that's a perfect example of that yes I
do need to send that email because I am
worried that I'm gonna get laid
and I need to get this information out
somehow and I I suffer from that
repeatedly so I think that when we think
of productivity test I think that it's
not only creating content or managing
content it's also about these
communication needs and how can we
design those to happen in a safe manner
and one thing I don't know if it's also
discussed here because I do work with a
lot of roadside safety experts one way
to actually measure how much you're
paying attention to the road the driving
test is actually even the way you drive
so for example if if you start swerving
around a lot and and I guess that's when
you your intelligence system maybe
should ask you and prom your question
are you okay and what are the things
that bother you that we can help
absolutely
Linda I hope it's okay let's just let's
say thank you to Shamsi I just want to
make sure that you guys get coffee and
so that we can go ahead and do the break
and then bio eight these are really
great comments so for those of you who I
did not get to please go ahead and write
the piece of paper you know your
comments so that we can tack it up and
then we'll try to group people together
to discuss so I'm gonna go ahead and do
my last presentation all of you can get
even on me now and take time to find out
if I'm going to be able to keep within
ten minutes I think I can though oh yeah
that's true right no no no so why didn't
I think of that no I'm just kidding
so I'm just gonna wrap up by talking
about you know everything that we
discussed with regards to trust using
our vehicle in the car and then what
happens over time when we use automation
and so I'm gonna talk about just
adapting to technology in our cars so I
spend a lot of time looking at
behavioral adaptation which is basically
when you have extended use of a system
what happens to the operator and how
their behavior may change based on use
of it and oftentimes it changes in way
that's unintended from the person who
actually designed the system and this
change can be based on many things in
addition to like what the situation is
the context and it's often based on you
know how much experience we have how
familiar we are with the situation as
well as what our motive
for what why we're driving to begin with
but what's very interesting is that you
know as technology has evolved
technology is right now adapting to the
limitations of the human but we are also
adapting to limitations of technology so
we're definitely technology while
technology is adapting to us and so from
that then we we see these different
types of implications and there's
actually many types but for this
particular workshop I just wanted to
focus on the perception of safe driving
what is what a drivers think is actually
safe when over time they're able to do
more and more things and they they were
able to do it without actually getting
into a safety critical incidents so then
therefore the amount of non driving
activities while driving then starts to
seem to seemingly increase and we
actually saw this we did a study where
we looked at people texting and reading
while they were driving and you can see
we did this just over three time periods
and overtime so we separated out these
individuals based on the driver
performance measures based on risk and
and and the more conservative driving
based on how close they are ahem how
what's their propensity speed and you'll
see that over time there are people that
are risky actually we're more willing to
do you know more texting and and spend
more time looking at their devices
compared to other other things so when
we look at automation it's really nice
because it can because it can extend the
capabilities of the humans but it can
also make the humans more complacent
during actually safety critical
situations so it's more vulnerable to
system failures to unexpected events as
well as cyber attacks and there may not
be as understanding of what's going on
so the operators in this case you know
based on all the previous talks can
actually experience degraded situation
awareness of what's going on they may
actually have D skilling as well as mode
confusion is to like you know what what
system is actually on or off and then of
course the over reliance and the over
trust in the system so you know I've
I've done this work where I looked at
you know how it would actually you know
adaptation impact our ability to use
things so well if we expect that you
know when we get a system our goal is
that that system should actually help
increase or enhance our performance over
time and immediately when we get it we
use it in such a way that yeah this is
cool but then over time you know we kind
of like plateau off and then we can't
actually operate at some optimum so we
just start to kind of like level off a
little bit and we're hoping that if we
get from our car to let's say a rental
car in another car that doesn't have
that system that we learn something from
that system because we've been using it
we understand when something is going to
occur and so we have this positive
transfer of behavior but oftentimes what
really happens is that we just go back
to our normal driving mode that what we
had before the worst case scenario is
because we've had you know so it's such
high dependence on the system we
actually have a negative transfer of
behavior and then that's a situation
where something actually bad can occur
we actually did a study to look at this
we've actually done several studies so
I'm just gonna report on one where we
looked at drivers behavior to link
Keeping Assist so for those I think all
of you know what this is but basically
he keeps delaine's we actually wanted to
see how people would adapt over time we
did use a driving simulator study but we
did this basically over three days for
eight different drives so we have them
do three different drives we have 48
participants half a little bit over half
use the Lane Keeping Assist and then we
had another group that basically had no
leg Keeping Assist so that we can just
do a comparison we had them basically
have a baseline drive with no swith no
secondary test no driver distractions no
anything then we had for those that were
in the automation group we also had them
just do the secondary task and then to
try to compare and we looked at
basically the driving performance
measures as well as their secondary task
performance and we also collected a
measure called TDR t and t dr t stands
for the tactile detection response task
this is actually based on the iso
standard that looks at assessing
attentional workload for cognitive loads
so it's as if you know you're driving
and you're doing a distracting task and
on how good are you able to like detect
pedestrians or other things on the road
that might actually have an impact so
the way this system marks is you
basically you you attach up this
vibrator to the person oftentimes on
their collarbone there's a micro switch
so this thing buzzes buzz buzz buzz buzz
and you're supposed to press whenever it
buzzes and so we actually measure
cognitive workload based on the accuracy
to perform this particular task as well
as how quickly they can respond to it
and then we also looked at their
propensity to take risk how often are
they willing to engage in the secondary
task while they're driving and so what
we see is that so for the blue line here
this is the control group these are for
people who actually have no link keeping
assist they just drive like what they
normally will and so you can see that
over time as you would expect they
become more and more used to the system
and they start listening less and less
targets and the treatment group which is
the Lane Keeping Assist we actually see
that same thing while they over time
they would decrease but what's very
interesting is that once that system is
taken away from them and we tell them
that the system is taken away they
actually miss more because they got used
to basically the system operating for
them and so even though they went down
there actually number of misses actually
goes up because now they have to
actually take back control of the system
and we noticed this even for secondary
task performance where if you see the
control group you know both of them kind
of increase in terms of you know doing
these types of secondary tasks because
they get engaged more but the people
that have the Lane Keeping Assist what
happens is they actually engage more in
more secondary tasks and then when the
system is taken away they actually
decrease because they're trying to still
maintain control so these and we have
also measures on driving performance so
if you look at the paper we have some
more information on that but I guess
just to sum up so I kept it really short
is that what I want to do is just kind
of get us to think about when we model
driver behavior what are some of the
things that we have to think about and
so for me there's like five things
number one we have to understand what
the system is what the system
limitations are the user and we talked a
lot about that there's not just age and
gender differences but cultural
differences as well as just geographical
differences then the context that we're
actually basically using the system what
tools that we are using to collect and
we talked about driving simulation
studies but also on road studies but
there's actually a whole space of
different types of studies like we have
colleagues that actually do things like
ghost riders where they actually like
hide some body and pretend that they're
actually driving an autonomous car we
have like died data gate and
interactions where somebody's in a
simulator in one place and somebody's
being a pedestrian simulator in another
and they're trying to interact with each
other so that there's this
vibrant needs to look at it and then the
types of data that we get from it is
also incredibly important and how we
actually bring all that together and
with that I actually end the more the
afternoon presentations and I open up
for questions ha
good timing thank you thank you clapping
for the timing or a further cut No okay
so I do want to open up for questions
just yeah Gamzee okay I will start so
you brought up this descaling with the
super interesting because now we are in
let's assume semi autonomous vehicles
where people are driving less and then
when it's a takeover or a handover
however you call it you're requiring
drivers to deal with situations that
they're probably even less prepared and
so my question here is that can we
design experiences or require people to
still have to drive for X amount of time
or design tasks in a way maybe that
causes them to drive and make sure that
they are keeping their skills that's a
really excellent question so earlier
today we somebody talked about training
because training is gonna become a
really big issue in terms of like what
are actually retraining people like even
just a young girl ever and then how much
regular training we have you know at
pilot with pilots they have n commercial
drivers they have like a set amount of
number of hours that they have to
actually be trained for so those are
things that people are looking at other
things that people are looking at are
you know given the fact that we're gonna
be using the cars differently does that
mean that you know every time something
is not working the way that we expect
are we just gonna go out and buy a new
car which is we're getting closer and
closer to that and I'll give you an
example like right now like we all use
washing machines right but there was a
time when people just washed clothes by
hand now if I wash machines Brooking do
we go back and wash our clothes by hand
or do we go out and buy a new washing
machine seriously so we we don't we very
rarely wash our clothes by hand anymore
so just something to kind of think about
as we're moving forward
yes I'm just wondering if you have also
had a look at some of the naturalistic
driving study data
be collected and by version as well as
in Australia they're about 300 to 400
drivers across more than four months and
they actually had one where they
installed a speed warning so when will
they be before they have the speed
warning device and after and the
treatment is and the treatment in fact
as well I've actually looked at lots of
naturalistic driving data I didn't show
here just for time but I've actually
looked at the data from the sharp - from
the hundred car study and also from the
University of Michigan Transportation
Research Institute which actually
collects a lot of field operational
tests their field operations tests
includes things like adaptive cruise
control lane departure warning and it
has before-and-after data so actually at
you know Eric mentioned earlier today
that we met actually at a National
Academies meeting and at that National
chasm meeting I actually talked about
the data from the naturalistic data
looking at adaptive cruise control and
we actually see actually information
about how people adapt to that system
over time and that we see differences in
terms of people and what's their
propensity to use things just one thing
to add as well as Karen Australian
contacts we have the P platers for
example out for the young drivers and
the if the impact on the different age
groups are quite different because when
they actually have the speed warning
they try to beat the system so it's
completely different
we've I 100% agree i'm just generalizing
right now but we've actually done
actually john lee and i we've actually
done a lot of studies looking at teen
drivers and young drivers and often
times we will see differences and how
feedback is actually like he talked
about coaching earlier but we actually
see that there are differences in how
younger drivers actually retain feedback
and and and then varies based on the
types of risks that they have and
whether or not they're risk aware or
risk seekers so yes I agree with you any
other questions yeah I'll breath and by
the way just how they adapt to things
over time - is very different I think
the question of gamification we see this
in many other areas and I think coming
to the descaling I think this is sort of
one of those things and we discussed if
gamification is one issue that could go
in there and I think but at the same
time when
ever you sort of require people to do
more you lose time but you could drive
automate it and so the other question
that comes in do we want to have the
person in the car driving taking over or
do you want to have a remote driver
taking over so I think that's something
again in in Europe at the moment of 5g
coming and a high density of cities we
see the technical possibility that we
can trust basically you your car is
coming into a different difficult
situation and you just hand it off or it
automatically is handed off to a
professional driver who sits somewhere
yeah and I think my feeling is what what
I have seen so far this is a much more
realistic handoff than to the driver who
has been sort of doing email and and
that goes is there sort of something
which goes in there right now the
research that I've been doing is not
really at that level of automation I'm
really focused more on the driver being
within the car but there is other people
that are doing research I don't know if
anybody else can talk about that where
basically the car drives drive drops you
off somewhere and then actually goes
back to your garage and waits for you
until you your your work with work week
is done I don't know if somebody else
has done some research on that
my research area has not focused on that
yeah Jesse did you want to comment so we
did something in today operation not in
a takeover scenario but in that there's
a room remote driver driving a unmanned
ground vehicle in military kind of
scenario one of the biggest biggest
problem we have is delay so because
usually in some situation their Wi-Fi is
not good there's huge delays between the
signal you send the signal between from
you sending the signal to the signal it
has reached the vehicle and that delay
makes the telly operator that they are
tasks very very demanding
the new standards for 5g which I think
is now being rolled out over the next
years has this one operation mode where
a single is 50 milliseconds or less to
get around that but I think it's a
question whether once we have coverage
or if the car can drive automatically
before that I think the goal for me was
trying to understand you know as we keep
increasing in automation
how do people adapt to these systems and
what are the things that they would do
differently that they would not do now
and how does that impact us you know
just overall in terms of use and with
that I I'm going to stop because I want
to make sure that you guys have coffee
and I also want to make sure that we
have time to kind of like go through the
stuff so just like before before you go
for coffee
please write down one more thing put it
up on the whiteboard and then and then
we'll keep going